let's go in-depth on these hearings
joining us tonight Ohio Republican Jim
Jordan of the House Intelligence
Committee thanks for being here
let's go over some logistics first what
do you anticipate next steps they make
the rules up as they go along they don't
even follow those so I assume they send
some kind of report to the Judiciary
Committee and then there'll be some kind
of process or let's hope it's some kind
of due process there but I have frankly
no idea because this has changed
throughout they were already doing
depositions then they hold a vote which
they couldn't even keep all their
members on in line for so we'll just
have to see what Pelosi and ship having
store for us next
well you move over to judiciary to do
some of that questionnaire so I'm on you
know Kevin when when the leader put me
over and tell I'm still on the Judiciary
Committee and still on the Oversight
Committee yes your guess is that it's
going to come to an impeachment vote
before the end of the year I do think
that's the path they're on but again you
never know with these guys I mean that
this was the most unfair process I've
ever seen we weren't allowed to call the
witnesses we want the ones we wanted
they ignored that even today they
haven't even released all the
depositions so there was certain
testimony given in these depositions
taken in the bunker in the basement the
Capitol that we could have been used in
the open hearing so we'll just have to
see but I anticipate that's my best get
best guess okay I want to go to some of
the substance today for example David
Holmes was there to testify about this
phone call between ambassador Sunland
and and the president United States
take a listen this is first ambassador
Taylor and then you're questioning the
member of my staff asked ambassador
Solomon what President Trump thought
about Ukraine master song and responded
that President Trump cares more about
the investigations of Biden why didn't
your boss bring up the call when I did
refer to the call on that meeting that
ambassador Taylor nodded knowingly as
though he had been briefed on it that's
not what asked I asked why he didn't
share with us I refer to the call and
everyone is nodding of course that's
what's going on of course the president
is pressing for a binding investigation
he doesn't share that one that Minister
I ordered mr. Joe you went down that
road and you get to this point where
some a lot of these witnesses said that
they came to the conclusion including
ambassador Sutherland he was a hundred
percent by September 8th
that the aid was tied to the
investigations of breezewood by Biden
and 2016 mr. Soglin said that there
there was an announcement that needed to
be made by president Solinsky that they
were going to do an investigation into
Brisbane the Biden's and before that if
that announcements not made they don't
get the call they don't get the meeting
they don't get the money they got the
call they got the meeting they got the
Security Assistance dollars and there
was never an announcement from president
Solinsky or frankly for that matter
anyone else in Ukraine and the
government so this idea that there was
this for that acquit for a quid pro quo
did not happen and yet they continue to
say whoa but this is impeachable this is
not about that at all breath this is
this is about they have never accepted
the will of the American people when 63
million Americans in an electoral
college landslide said we're gonna send
Donald Trump to Washington to shake that
town up and the establishment here and
particularly Democrats have never
accepted that they're gonna do whatever
it takes Muller report FBI investigation
dossier or now this whatever it takes to
try to get him out that's what this is
really about only pressure on a couple
things one is you buy that these
professionals didn't Tibor yzma to Biden
all these guys saying like Volker and
song one secretary Perry didn't tie that
buoy Zuma had to do with Joe Biden I do
some of them did tie it to that but it
still didn't happened there was no
announcement of investigation some of
them didn't kurt volker though he's got
a distinguished career he was this
special envoy he was the guy who was the
viewer Tom he was the definitive
narrative on this in fact he was the
first witness that Adam Schiff called
and yet his testimony has been the one
that I think best tells this entire
story this entire episode where there
was never a quid pro quo the aide
ultimately got delivered sometimes these
things get held up we heard testimony
from lots of people talking about that
as well so it all worked out in the end
but you had a brand new president new
guy never been in politics kind of
similar to what we got in this in this
country with our president knew had
never been in politics and we wanted to
check him out and people did for the the
55 days that the aide was held we
checked this guy's out the vice
president bastard Bolton US senators
bipartisan US senators went there and
met with this guy and they all come back
and said this he's the real deal he's a
reformer go ahead and release the
dollars and that's exactly what
President Trump did right well
ambassadors on the calls president Trump
on September 9th when that call happens
and the president's referenced it many
times how
nothing I want nothing no query Poirot
at the same time the House Intelligence
Committee launches this investigation
based on the whistleblower I mean you
don't see a coincidence I don't I don't
because like I said you had the vice
president vice president Pence met with
this guy you had the reforms they did in
their Parliament their Rada the reforms
where they started this anti-corruption
Court where they got rid of the former
prosecutor the reforms that were that
were needed plus you had a president
remember Donald Trump's not a big the
president Trump's not a big fan of
foreign aid in the first place he wants
European countries to share more of the
burden he understood the corruption
problem Ernst and Young said Ukraine's
one of the three most corrupt countries
on the planet plus he was concerned
about influence in the 2016 election and
things Ukrainian politicians were doing
to encourage Hillary Clinton to win
helping Hillary Clinton win and against
President Trump he was all that package
and he said oh by the way you got a new
president so he said let's check this
guy out
and what we did everyone come back and
said all right Cindy a when you hear
Democrats say okay if it's all on the
up-and-up why don't you give us Mick
Mulvaney why don't you give us John
Bolton why don't you release the
documents in the White House in the
State Department to complete the picture
if it's all on the up-and-up what I said
yesterday is if it was a fair process
then you can ask us that question but
until this process gets any any
semblance of fairness until we have some
actual due process for the minority and
more importantly for the President of
the United States until we get to that
but when we get those things done maybe
then we can talk about that but that's
the White House's call but I see that
the American people see how unfair this
has been throughout so that's the main
thing we need is a fair process you
think that the president will be
impeached in the house look that vote a
few weeks ago I think was you know they
got the numbers but I think what was
most telling about that vote a few weeks
ago is two Democrats came over to our
side my guess is there'll be a few more
Democrats come our way whether we can
have enough to stop them from sent it to
the Senate I don't know it doesn't look
it doesn't look promising but let's hope
so because putting the country through
this is not healthy particularly 11
months before the next election based on
an anonymous whistleblower with no
first-hand knowledge bias against the
president who work with Joe Biden that
we don't even get to bring in front of
us having put his hand up and swear
under oath to tell the whole truth
nothing about the truth see what
kind of biases he has what his
motivation was for starting this whole
thing that's that's the part that
bothers so many Americans why they know
instinctively this is unfair that's
thing representative we'll heard your
colleague on the committee said he
didn't like the call he thought it was
inappropriate can you get there no I
mean look President Trump has his own
way of conducting business I like the
way he operates I think the American
people like a guy who comes here and
shaking this town up and and again as I
said the facts are on the president's
side and the American people understand
that this process has been a totally
unfair Twitter question have you ever
worn a jacket I have you have to wear
one on the floor the House floor and I
always wear one I went I'm around the
president congressman thanks thank you